et maintenant voici joe cocker
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je cocker bonsoir
toi tu avais merci d'être avec nous aux
jo ou avec 33 27
on a gardé nos boys
il est possible que lost wade chaque
jour alors pour tous ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas joe cocker joe cocker
c'est ça
week end
hélas
[Musique]
le ca aurait un choix
oui
au revoir
à temps
à
yu
le forum
ok
[Musique]
à
panucci
des gosses
akram cheema roll
patchouli
[Musique]
oh
là
n'oubliez jamais
c'est
sauf que voilà joe cocker jakab
d'émotion melissmell bientôt terminé une
chanson qui me semble que tu as oublié
ouais tout au début un alan a chanté un
truc c'est pas joe cocker ah oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vois ton corps dites nous ce que vous
pensez de ce chanteur vraiment
sérieusement
oui
[Musique]
voir
à 100
what do you think services c'est une
femme oui voilà alors en plus du dvd
joe cocker sort un nouvel album didier
m
mais après
bebehabs
[Musique]
m
bravo
[Musique]
migration
barcap 5 the do
[Musique]
allez voir
tél
jeanne thum fo
ah oui
thomas explique je fais
habib kane douche qu'un show
[Musique]
ap
12-4 ou
[Musique]
e
des casses jake locker le dernier album
s'appelle entame sa carrière
bravo
alors qui est incroyable avec avec vous
au joe cocker c'est que vous avez eu
énormément de succès et pourtant vous
n'êtes pas un performeur vous n'êtes pas
un showman géré quand vous êtes sur
scène vous pourrez pas dans tous les
sens comme mick jagger ou rod stewart
vous êtes derrière votre micro oui c'est
tout à fait exact en fait j'utilise un
micro droit devant moi un micro fixé et
donc je peux pas courir bon quand
j'étais plus jeune c'est vrai que
j'utilisais un micro portable quand je
tenais dans la main mais maintenant même
si j'ai une voix plutôt grave
j'ai l'impression d'être un petit peu
comme un chanteur d'opéra mais ça me
permet de nous de faire passer mon
message
ça c'est la première raison déjà c'est
pas un showman et puis deuxièmement vous
n'avez fait que des reprises ya très peu
de chansons qui ont été écrites par vous
même parce que j'ai dit je ne sais pas
jouer d'un instrument
donc quand j'ai une mélodie dans la tête
elle s'en va tout de suite et finalement
vous avez fait votre succès sur des
reprises en lait en les améliorant d'une
certaine façon non moins jeu ce que je
pense c'est que ce sont mes propres
interprétations il ya des gens qui font
des reprises depuis des années ça c'est
quelque chose de normal c'est tout à
fait naturel on a mis à chanter les
chansons des autres mais en fait les
gens n'aiment pas forcément un lien
aussi fort que moi avec ses chanteurs
donc moi j'essaye d'ajouter une petite
touche de joe cocker à toutes mes
chansons des beatles par exemple quand
vous avez fait with a little help from
my friends les beatles vous avez envoyé
un télégramme de félicitations parce
qu'il trouvait que l'interprétation de
joe cocker était mieux que la leur
j'adore bono ouais one il a très bien
fait
ouais absolument alors joe cocker votre
truc en fait c'est votre voix
vous dites d'ailleurs c'est un c'est un
cadeau c'est ça c'est un don du ciel
cette voie non ça dépend de données du
côté de qu'elle vous placez par un
moratoire mais au fil des ans il faut
bien voir que j'ai travaillé ma voix
mais j'ai essayé de maintenir mon
patrimoine et maintenant j'ai atteint
l'âge fatidique de 60 ans est bon vous
savez il faut dire que je jamais pensé
que j'atteindrai cet âge là vous vous
buvez combien de verres de mazout par
jour pour avoir cette voie vous savez
j'ai arrêté de boire voilà trois ans non
mais quand je lisais quand on chante
dans des bars etc
on reste sur beaucoup de fumée et c'est
vrai que sur vos paquets de cigarettes
ya marqué tu me dois tout ça j'ai arrêté
aussi j'ai arrêté de faire les quelques
années car vous pouvez plus d'alcool
turc à coeur vous ne buvez pas d'alcool
depuis trois ans ce qui fait que lorsque
vous retournez dans votre ville natale
sheffield ville minière du nord de
l'angleterre
si le service public finalement vous
n'êtes pas content du tout parce que
d'abord ils sont tous jaloux de vous
parce que tous les mecs avec qui vous
buviez au peuple il ya des années vous
avez réussi pas eux et ensuite ils
continuent à boire et vous vous avez
arrêté ce qui fait que vous ne
retournais jamais dans cette ville de
sheffield
non c'est vrai que je rentre pas très
souvent à sheffield
vous avez raison thierry il ya un petit
peu d'amertume de du côté des musiciens
que j'ai connu quand j'étais plus jeune
qui n'ont pas réussi comme et donc
lorsque je rentre pays c'est un petit
peu difficile de m'identifier à eux dans
la cigarette vous l'avait arrêté après
un voyage en australie vous avez passé
15 heures dans un avion vous êtes devenu
fou il y a parce que je sais pas si vous
êtes déjà allé en australie en avion
mais c'est vraiment long et donc 15
heures donc il est bien possible de
fumer et donc vous avez arrêté la drogue
si john ans y est vous avez rencontré
votre femme pam à santa barbara la fin
des années 70 c'est grâce à elle que
vous avez
vous avez arrêté la drogue sans pam vous
seriez morts oui c'est vrai qu'elle m'a
beaucoup aidé à sortir de ces moments
difficiles
c'est difficile d'expliquer à qui que ce
soit vous savez lorsque vous tombez
vraiment dans le gouffre parce qu'il
faut bien voir que je chantais toujours
je serai toujours mes tournées etc
mais il faut dire que j'avais perdu un
peu le ma passion alors aujourd'hui vous
habitez dans le colorado joe dans un
manoir anglais que vous avez fait
construire dans le colorado
alors écoute bien la vie qu'il a
maintenant quand même vous élever des
vaches
vous aiderez des chevaux de course vous
pêcher à la mouche et vous fait des
balades avec votre chien
c'est exactement ça ouais c'est pas
casque ou non c'est pas c'est pas ça va
c'est en fait c'est bizarre parce que
quand je reviens en tournée tout de
suite je passe en mode nuit et donc je
reste éveillé jusqu'à 3 heures du matin
mais quand je retourne au colorado et
bien tout de suite je passe en mode jour
et à ce moment là je me lève le matin à
6h30 et puis je vais me balader dans le
forez et j'adore ça ça me plaît beaucoup
en fait c'est simplement un contraste
vraiment saisissant est intéressant pour
c'est pas très rock'n'roll
je sais je sais bien alors ça vous
change femme de woodstock
cinq cent mille personnes tu sais ça car
et tu vas pas connu ça toi woodstock il
a chanté devant 500 mille personnes
s'étaient plus - c'est pas d'air
c'est pas très agréable c'est pas le
meilleur concert de votre vie et
j'imagine mais au delà de 50 mille
personnes vous savez on est dans une
sorte d' un petit peu à part c'est un
petit peu comme je suis pas assez c'est
un petit peu ailleurs on sait pas qui
nous écoutent vraiment sais pas si les
gens nous écoutent et donc il est
vraiment difficile d'expliquer ce qu'on
ressent mais en fait c'est qu'il ya un
problème et un niveau de conscience en
fait il est difficile d'avoir le même
niveau de conscience que que les gens
qui sont présents dans la salle
et donc ce show qu'on a fait
j'ai mis ce que j'aime bien c'est faire
des shows où l'on me voit vraiment on
voit vraiment les gens ça c'est bien il
ya des chanteurs en france ils font 50
milles dans toute leur vie à woodstock
ce qui a fait merveille
ce sont vos hurlements vos
gesticulations qui était très inattendu
pour l'époque
et alors quand vous êtes passés dans le
ed sullivan show qui a été la grosse
émission c'était drucker quoi quand vous
êtes passés dans cette émission il y
avait des danseuses qui se mettait
devant les caméras pour peau parce que
les producteurs voulaient pas qu'on vous
voit en fait il voulait pas que les
américains vous vois dieu même fihri et
the quelques années auparavant eu elvis
il faut pas oublier ça et donc vous
savez comment je faisais mes petits mais
petit à petit frustration le fait que je
puisse pas jouer le piano le fait que je
vous aime les choses mais en fait j'ai
pas vraiment conçu pour que je fais
d'ailleurs quand je le fais mais bon moi
je faisais j'étais plus démonstratif à
l'époque je faisais un petit peu peur
aux gens et donc quand ils ont commencé
à me voir faire tout ça ils se sont
joints à des spasmes ce type ça va pas
donc ils ont mis des filles devant moi
en espérant que je serai cacher est ce
que le rock'n'roll est mort jo
le vrai r'n'b je pense que ça va jamais
mourir parce que ça c'est si ça pose des
jalons de toute la musique que nous
connaissons pour le bac 8
alors on va voir ce qui est mort et ce
qui est pas mort on va faire l'interview
c'est mort alors joe cocker est ce que
les cheveux longs c'est mort c'est
vraiment la mauvaise personne à qui vous
posez la question lorsque je vois ce qui
se fait on fonce toujours qu'on a des
cheveux vous savez mais bon est-ce que c
des branches et oui peut-être est-ce que
la libération sexuelle c'est mort non je
ne prends pas je ne crois pas je pense
que les choses sont un petit peu évolué
depuis mon époque c'est est ce que les
tournée en bus à travers les états unis
ces morts tournée prévue l'année
prochaine aux etats-unis est un tournant
car s'il ya un film qui a été fait sur
joe cocker et lee ann russell qui
s'appelle mad dog and englishmen sur une
tournée qui l'a fait aux états unis dans
les années 70 et tuent les voyages et
puis il ya trente musiciens il ya les
femmes les enfants les chiens c'est
extraordinaire c'est un film est sorti
en dvd d'ailleurs mad dog and english
man est ce que les concerts sous la
pluie avec des milliers de fans sous
acide
c'est mort vous savez quand on a fait
wittstock ce qui était un petit peu
bizarre c'est que c'était le seul type
qui avait pas pris de l'acide et donc il
avait oublié d'en mettre deux un jus
d'orange
est-ce que les long solo à la guitare
gibson c'est mort 1
allez on essaie je vois pas trop les les
guitaristes et faire ça 28 vous faites
je sais pas si c'est vraiment ce que je
préfère d'ailleurs c'est pas vraiment à
jimi hendrix est ce que jouer de la
guitare avec les dents c'est mort il n'y
a pas beaucoup de gens qui arrivent à le
faire comme hendrix de toute façon avec
les dents donc est ce que les filles
dans votre lit après les concerts c'est
mort ben voila mon dieu ça fait un
moment
est ce que votre femme dans votre lit
après un concert c'est mort alors elle
est en inde qu'en l'instant avec une
amie et donc elle ne travaillerais ne
voyage pas tant que ça avec moi mais
c'est dommage d'ailleurs est ce que john
lennon c'est mort ce qui me rassure
c'est qu'ils ont pas laisser sortir ce
type ils ont par relâcher parce que je
pense que quelqu'un se serait occupé non
john lennon ne sera jamais ça c'est sûr
jamais mon beaucoup d'inspiration
est-ce que ce paul mccartney c'est mort
toujours été un petit peu morne
c'est vrai je l'admets mais il me faut
bien voir qu'il est toujours un petit
peu trop carré j'ai préféré c'est vrai
est-ce que sex drugs and rock and roll
c'est mort bienne aura mis un bon et si
j'avais 25 ans j'aurais peut-être un
avis différent mais mais pour moi oui
ils sont enfin je sais pas quelque chose
qui marche encore pour certains en tout
cas au goût de certains
bien sûr nous avons besoin peuvent en un
an
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus